got some breaking news coming in
concerning the salisbury
novichok poison it's the second as you
can see there the second
poisoning suspect has been identified
his true
identity has been uncovered as you can
also see there from the the grab we're
showing on the screen there by the
investigative website
bellingcat he's been identified as dr
alexander
mishkin uh he masqueraded as alexander
petrov
when he visited salisbury but the
website bellincat has
identified him finally as dr alexander
mishkin the the doctor refers to the
fact that he is a trained
medical doctor read into that what you
will it comes about two weeks
after uh the first suspect was
identified
he went under the name as ruslan borisov
he was identified by the website as
colonel
and anatoly chapiga a member of the
gru the russian military
intelligence operation both men it turns
out
have paid extensive visits uh according
to bellingham
to ukraine over the past few years
and more details emerging on the website
which
i believe our foreign affairs editor
deborah haynes uh
can take us through she joins me now
from the sky center so uh the bones
there of uh
what uh this man this uh dr mishkin uh
what
what he is and where he comes from uh
what more do we know what more's been
uncovered
absolutely well i i can confirm that the
name
is what the british authorities believe
to be the true identity of the second
suspect
um the benincat website once again has
caught everybody short by being able to
reveal the identity
of supposedly secret russian agents uh
it must be giving
president putin pause for thought what
we know from
what's been revealed on the website and
we can't independently confirm all the
details yet
um is that this um this gentleman
mr michigan or dr mishkin uh was
apparently 39 years old
he is apparently a military doctor for
the gru
previously he was apparently a military
doctor for the russian navy
when he joined the secret service berlin
cat says that he
spent time in ukraine he kept that
identity for a number of years
and traveled extensively on it before he
was
allegedly deployed to salisbury earlier
this year alongside
the second gentleman who was revealed
almost two weeks ago by bellingcat
and the insider which is a russian
investigative
um outlet as uh colonel um
topega and i think if you remember that
man um he was identified as as being a
you know a russian military hero having
received
russia's highest honor for uh bravery in
terms of the work that he had done
for the russian state the two of them
traveling on aliases when they came to
salisbury
and if you remember they were outed by
the british authorities last month
under their aliases with their
identities their photographs revealed
and that's the information that the
bellingcat website worked upon
to to sift through various databases
to find their true identities um it
remains to be see what russia
says well what the kremlin says in
response to this they've
denied uh consistently any involvement
in the salisbury
attack and have claimed rather
ludicrously it has to be said
that these two men were tourists
traveling to salisbury to see the
beautiful cathedral
and i think even the most ardent
supporters of the russian state
find that quite hard to believe just
given that their demeanor and given the
amount of time they spent on the ground
and
given that they were deterred by things
like slush